I'm just saying your logic is sound sir
you have a franchise where every
characters be loved
and let's just put it out there or just
let them play Apex Legends
to play these beloved characters that's
there you know you're talking about Jedi
falling order that's a one-off that's a
Star Wars franchise you have the Star
Wars people that's gonna buy it some
people don't even open it because they
just want to be part of the Star Wars I
feel you but there's been plenty of Star
Wars games that didn't know because they
just weren't good games yes
Star Wars Battlefront 2 with all the
issues it had still did well wow there's
there's clearly why obviously because
they turned it around why because the
gameplay was good and I can be Darth
Vader and I can be Luke Skywalker I'm
sorry Star Wars hey you're not a Star
Wars head so Star Wars heads is gonna go
with Star Wars heads want to be okay now
you can have crappy games in series
they just won't sell but